ma perché il menu di un videogioco deve
essere così inquietante ma possibile mai
verdetti ragazzi e per molte persone
video io sono faringei sono contento di
registrare questo video sono
contentissimo di fare lo youtube come
mestiere benestanti su amy di wall
street lei mi ero dimenticato dove
eravamo rimasti anzi mi son di 22 sono
rimasti scusate a ciò è vero che doveva
entrare nel si fa di nuovo tutto il giro
devo fare ma che palle non vedo nulla
non vedo non vedo come nulla quella e
satana viva quella e satana
[Musica]
bene comunque io ero arrivato più avanti
di questo punto semplicemente non mi ha
salvato la partita quanto sono contento
di questo andiamo avanti
mettete una canzone di sottofondo una
roba decente che se voce regata yakin
cui adesso ha acceso la luce
devo arrivare in quella porta libera
arrivarci devo fare il giro di tutto
tutto il posto e non è che sia così
anche perché non mi ricordo neanche più
da dove siamo passati l'ultima volta di
qua giusto possiamo andare in questo
posto bellissimo bene siamo arrivati
davvero arrivata un'altra volta
fantastico nessuno ora bertone 4 ecco
qualcuno mi spiega che cosa
togliete le cuffie
io non lo faccio tanto non ho più i
timpani prove ma non mi fa ripartire
tutto dall'inizio dalle scatole per
cortesia a no ma dai ma serio ma dovevi
farmi tutto sto casino ogni volta siete
scemi
aridaje qua maledizione fatemi vedere
dove dovrei andare a sinistra
scacciavano a destra porca eva morta
ieri a sinistra dritto destra subito
deve evitare di prendere i vicoli ciechi
in poche parole c'è cosa che io sono
sempre brava a fare c'è una niente si sa
è aiuto
c'è poi da qualche parte che è brutto
posto ma maniera meno le prima
beh allora rassicuranti simo guarda è
chiusa ma guarda non mi dire non avrei
mai detto se mi spunta qualcuno qui
denunci programmatori del gioco ve lo
giuro cosa sto casino qua o era una
tessera porca vacca quella della metro
ma poi scusami la porta non c'e la
tessera la chiave è una chiave non è
possibile allora vedi che c'è una
serratura dove l'ho messa la tessera no
vabbè se io ho fatto tutto sto
ci son fatto di gusto ragazzino per
tornare indietro sono andato avanti per
tornare stilate stai tranquillo link i
capi state fissa le tende posso andare
in bagno non posso andare manco in bagno
mi chiede gioco brutto proprio non è che
sia aperto st porta per caso ma guarda
mi sorprende tanto il fatto che non si
sia aperta guardate che sfiga questo
bagno almeno libero alcune donne era
occupato giustamente no ma questo non
puoi pisciare nel bagno delle donne nel
bagno degli uomini non puoi andare nella
stanza delle fotocopie che c'è un
pagliaccio girato contro il muro posso
andare qua nell'art nel nella warehouse
cessata nella warehouse è che diciamo
così che chi sono porto o perfetta una
stanza libera c'è
ma avete abbastanza personaggi da
rompermi le palle in tutte le stanze
chiaro è mai del sic in the dark trova c
io vi devo trovare anche lì devo
toccarli a dirlo subito mi sembra molto
chiara una cosa vedo satana a guardare
il muro la prima cosa mi andava retto
carlo giustamente non è successo niente
funziona
eccoti ciao gino mamma mia prima tutti
gli ho trovati volo troverò più nessuno
è pensato a vedere
e poiché fame ma dove dovrebbe essere
poi c'era il pagliaccio sei bellissima
oppure turno anche anche quella coi
capelli bianchi
ok allora manca il nano
poi dopo il ma non c'è non c'è ancora
uno schifo figurate chi è il demonio che
manca è figura solo
ecco ho trovati dai con ricordi con i
ragazzi è stato bello non so chi magari
è chiuso pure mi mancano le mie bambole
ma la sveglia adesso video esatto ma mai
ma capello ma capello
dove mamma mamma non era lui mancava
quello che diceva mamma quello lì li
mortacci mia abbiamo ricerchiamo di
tutti uno è ma non ci stanno più
ma non è che hanno cambiato location
adesso ma perché potrebbero girarmi i
trequarti ve lo dico
lo schifo non l'avevo visto bene 12
hanno capito come i posti
perfetto sia contento che si divertano
sono vivaci belli questi ragazzi e 34
mancano quelli nei cessi e in teoria
dovremmo aver finito dovrebbero essere
sei credo arrivo rieccolo 5 tra tutti si
sente solo lui
che bello 56 manca il sesto di un
pagliaccio legati era qua prima
schifosamente andato con l'uomo
eccolo perfetto ai dancing in the dark
tua sorella in ilike tutti e se ce li ho
tutti
no ragazzi li ho tutti dai non rompete i
trequarti ce li ho tutti basta o 7 a mi
piace non altro sono sette figurati dove
sono sempre qui fra tutti i muri di
merda se ci mancano solo i muri guarda
com'è possibile che sia buio fuori e
luna sisto rumore e vabbè allora ditelo
voi siete stracci ma stiamo scherzando
solo scherzando ma basta è smesso di
seguirmi fottutissimo stalker maniaco ci
fa qui no nel bagno no su un idiota
ha cercato un attimo di capire come sia
prima in quale maniglia però guarda
quanta rho allunga la mano prendi una
granata in fila già nell'anno la
smettete di mandarmi messaggi di un
momento delicato della mia vita questo
grazie su cup for cross schifo quanto
dura sono riuscito a chiudere la porta è
difficilissimo bye bye bye bye bye
veloce dieci minuti ce l'abbiamo fatto
noi un'ora che corno basta succhia ce
l'ho fatta lega guarda le due le 21 ora
correre con un idiota e stato orribile
c'è ve lo giuro i miei peggiori incubi
ma dove attendere di nuovo sembrerebbe
di sì stavolta è molto più lento di
prima pure novara già ci mancava
ok boschi focoso visto posso visto le
verifiche di chimica visto va bene
ragazzi non so cosa devo fare in questa
parte non lo voglio sapere in realtà
però lo re sono contento di essere
arrivato fino qua visto che sto sempre
di più di me stesso il che è un bene i
ragazzi si vede sia piaciuto
quando mi piace anche ai ritorni come
schizzare servizi di schede non ci
vediamo da ragazzi
[Musica]